okay good evening everybody or good
afternoon in fact still and welcome to
this reconvened meeting of the executive
and which was originally to take place
last week and we were able to transact
some of the items on the agenda and but
there were a number are standing at the
point where we had some technical issues
so we will be dispensing with the rest
of the agenda from this point and what I
would say is obviously just a with
regard to item one that on this occasion
we have apologies from councillor Slater
and but we did have a politician
councillor Freeman last week he is here
on this occasion so that that deals with
that we've received no questions from
the public and and given that the
attendance is different from members of
the executive other any declarations of
interest from executive members in any
of the items on the agenda no okay thank
you so moving through the agenda we've
already dispensed with items four five
and six
so item seven is turn moths dedications
as a village green councillor right
please
Thank You leader this is a really
positive paper which sets out our
intention to designate Moss as a village
green the friends group up some very
exciting and ambitions plans plans for
the site and this designation will help
to realise those plans and give the
community some security over its future
it will also protect against unwanted
development of the site for alternative
uses the friends group have been
successful in receiving a 10,000 pound
grant from the social investment fund
and some of the short and long term
aspirations for the Friends of term us
include new signage in and around the
site improved connectivity with
surrounding area sorry cycling and
walking paths improved improved sporting
facilities new trees and biodiversity
projects and a new activity playing area
improvements to the central parking area
a new Vista information board benches
and general improvement proven
the application process is expected to
take between one and three months Thank
You leader counselor right under
councilor fatale if there was anything
that you'd like to add as the executive
member thoroughly sure and support at
all
thank you just just briefly very much
welcome this report its testament to the
to the work of the Friends of Tomas and
I look forward to working positively
with that group to bring forward some
really exciting plans for the site thank
you Thank You Council at the tail are
there any questions or comments from
members of the executive if you could
raise your hand in the electronic manner
and which is available to you okay and
there any questions or comments more
widely if members could use the raise
hand function and possible freeze
I'm not seeing any hands raised okay the
recommendations are as set out in the
report could I ask members of the
executive and to unmute and confirm
whether they are happy to approve those
please thank you item eight is the
Jubilee sensor Boden counselor writes
again please Thank You leader this is
another really positive report which
sets out our ambition to deliver a new
and improved multifunction community
facility and a high quality residential
development that will include a
contribution to the council's affordable
housing targets in not just one of the
most unaffordable parts of Trafford but
one of the most unaffordable parts of
the UK the scheme is also expected to
deliver a net return of approximately
1.7 million pounds the council at the
time post Kovac but any financial
returns to a local authority has to be
welcomed not just if this an exciting
opportunity to regenerate a site not fit
for purpose but is also it is also an
opportunity for the council to add to
its housing targets we are hopeful that
the contract with the procured partner
will beginning July 21 and working
comments on the site soon after
depending on planning permission etc
however given the caveats of working in
a postcode world this could of course
change depending on the economic
circumstances and there's the report
thank you but not everybody has the
chance they'd like to come in at all
members of the executive and then any
questions or comments more widely he
could indicate in the chance then I'll
bring you in
okay doesn't seem to be any questions or
comments there so the recommendations
are as though to set out in the report
could I ask members of the executive to
unmute and confirm whether they're happy
to approve that please thank you and
moving on
item 9 is councilor right again I'm Hale
library please Thank You leader and I'm
in fear of repeating myself here but
this is the third of three very positive
reports I bring to exec this afternoon
as I'm sure members will be aware it was
agreed over five years ago the the then
executive member for transformation
Resources agreed the disposal of our
library site to health community
trusting Hillcrest homes it should be
noted that although west yield limited
have replaced Hillcrest as developer a
formal agreement hasn't yet been signed
between HCT and them to dissolve the
partnership and this will need to be
formalized before the council enters
into the contract as you will note from
the report the sale of this site is
significantly below market value however
as an executive we accept that financial
value is not the only value that should
be imply notwithstanding the financial
savings the council will benefit from
from Jayceon going running costs and
maintenance this will also provide a new
library for Hale and significant
improvements to the library and
community facilities in that area the
residential properties will add to the
council's housing targets and provide
much-needed council tax revenues it is
anticipated that both both sites will be
completed in June 2021 I move the report
thanks leader Thank You council the
right any questions or comments from
members of the executive he could pop
and the indication in the chat any
questions or comments more widely he
could do the same and just indicate in
the chat function please
No okay the recommendations are as set
out in the report - may be approved
please I thank you item 10 is the update
on the Greater Manchester cleaner plan
councillor Oxford please yourself there
thank you yes the report provides a
comprehensive update on where the
cleaner plan is up to as you may recall
from previous reports there was concerns
than the like clarity from ministers
before Parliament was closed the general
election and obviously following that we
had the Christmas break and obviously
with new minister says look there was
still a lot of lack of get be able to
get information on those concerns around
the existing timetable even at that
early point in the year then of course
we since then we've had Cove aid and
this has affected the area were like
most things it was also knew delay of
implementation that is now planned for
2022 however I do understand that
potentially a that the timeline in which
traffic would be compliant would remain
unchanged which was previously the first
year of implementation however I thought
some change that could well be before we
actually implement the scheme itself
this is actually good news the report
before us gives details of the
background to the clean air plan and
includes a comprehensive timetable of
events and the progress of the different
aspects of the work today including
information on the clean vehicle funds
along the information concerning the
effects Cobra has had on the proposed
formal public consultation the
government has accepted its effects on
this work and whilst it was not
preventers making preparations for
consultation the situation with Kovach
remains unclear at this point and the
definitive decision as to when to start
the formal consultation remains unclear
at this point potentially the autumn
however preparations for the different
scenarios will be part of that ongoing
work and as it does work with all
stakeholders and over equally
on the background well that actually
helps to support their strategy no
viewer look at sections 9 on evey
charging and sections 10 on the
decarbonisation of transport these are
actually all integral to the work we're
currently doing and they're actually
pleased to see they've actually included
in this report which is really helpful
I still section 11 on the tax aluminum
standards and while these were all huge
pieces of work in their own right I
think would all be agreed it makes sense
to include information in this report to
highlight that this is an old John
demented a with that leader I will
actually a beautiful and way any
questions thank you thank you any
questions or comments remembers of the
questions or comments more widely
I have counselor Collins Thank You chair
and so yes it's a progress here and
obviously welcomes am 41 million from
from government to give grants and loans
for the the changes needed and I hope
that we'll be able to prioritize this in
some way to support the small businesses
the taxis and other small companies that
risk being the ones in the most
difficult situation by these important
changes and and then secondly I suppose
I'm wondering about I'm quite worried
about the delays we know that at the
moment we're going to be breathing
illegally dirty air in Greater
Manchester until 2024 and um we now have
a delay and we're likely to I think I
just mentioned we might be starting
consultation in autumn we do know that
we may be facing a second or third
lockdown do we have contingency plans to
carry out consultations rapidly if that
is to be the case and given that Kovac
is a respiratory illness we have you
know increasingly hearings and evidence
that it may well be impacted by air
pollution
it surely seems more and more important
that we don't have people grieving and
illegally dirty air for for four more
years let
the danger that that goes on even longer
and finally and there's no discussion in
here as in previous documents of the
potential of going to the more radical
Cass D plan so again as we're coming out
of lockdown cities around the world are
looking at taking even more radical
steps with taking all polluting vehicles
out of their their city centers and
really opening up city centers and for
the people who live and work and spend
time there and is that something that
we're really unwilling to consider yes
thank you leader yes I mean only final
point there first as you will be aware
council Coggins er that's been discussed
a number of times now it's been in
previous reports category D scheme has
been considered but it will not help
with bringing forward that the debt the
date of compliance across Greater much
therefore you would actually penalize
people without actually any real
advantage of actually making it sooner
so in that sense it also affect the
poorest people in our society and as
that actually would not help the
implementation forward any sooner there
were no advantages in that point of it
there I think the main point exactly
needs to get this implemented classes I
did indicate earlier also counsel
cooking's in my opening comments that
that the date to traffic as fast note
would remain unchanged so as previously
we would been compliant within the first
year of implementation the scheme as a
day itself remains unchanged that means
that in traffic we will be compliant
before implementation of the scheme so
I'm sure you'd actually welcome that and
of course the taxis and small businesses
we do support that and obviously at the
point of actually having the clean
vehicle funds and I just want make sure
that it gets to the people and those
organizations types and individuals
doing this as soon as possible and as I
think it is out rounding the core and I
mean I did mention as well that we're
actually not waiting for the and the
scheme such darkness but actually snow
even now even in Colvard women actually
having those discussions with people so
I think that's a and that's got ongoing
piece of work
in terms of consultation yes I mean
we're not completely clear helps me
effective book at the moment in time we
are planning for an Alton consultation
once it wants the consultation is
carried out and we've got that
information back from the public that
then obviously we will actually be
moving try to get the scheme in as soon
as possible in that sense it so I mean
I'm hopeful and I'm actually yeah I do
believe that we can actually do this in
those timelines and the second wave does
come in the winters Jessie by that point
the consultation itself will be over
with and we can get on with implementing
the scheme so I think there's some good
news there on it is a delighted what
code word has affected everything in
society and I think it's one of those
things nobody likes it nobody wanted
these delays but however I think as I
did indicate it does mean that an
interim that work in the background is
still going on so it's all work we're
working with the organized Asian
stakeholders and looking at how we can
all this comes from infrastructure point
of view that is all still ongoing and
that far as part of the work so that's a
that is not being delayed that passerby
we need the public consultation formal
public consultation and that will be
happening and they could do any updates
on it we will actually make sure that
all members get the information as soon
as possible Thank You leader Thank You
councillor I said I just answer that by
way of clarification with regard to the
specific points around the ability to
consult should there be a doubt break
and it's it's it's fair to say that that
would be a material consideration for it
in terms of and how we would respond to
that largely because one of the reasons
that the delay has been required is that
we need to ensure the legitimacy and the
robustness of any consultation that
takes place and clearly there are two
extreme positions in this in this debate
and we would need to make sure that from
a legal perspective we were not left
exposed to legal challenge by either end
of that spectrum and and certainly one
way in which a legal challenge may have
some weight is if the consultation
process that was to one unfold was in
any way unsatisfactory so that was the
reason for the initial delay but it's
probably also why we couldn't say within
at this point what the response would be
to any second wave of Kovac I just
wanted to pick up as well with my
Greater Manchester hunt on the the
comments around the funding that has
been received to date you quite right
that we've received 41 million
councillor coffins that is of a total of
166 million and unfortunately it is
ring-fenced to certain areas of spend
within that and we're not yet at a
position where we have either and a full
amount of funding available but also in
particular a particular clarification on
the funding package that will be
available for taxis and that is a real
and material concern for us moving
forward clearly as an industry they will
be very very heavily impacted by this
and whilst it is the right thing to do
to implement a clean air zone we do need
to ensure that small businesses taxi
drivers and others that are impacted by
this have the necessary support in place
so so I am in regular correspondence
with I think my third minister now in
just over a year of doing this job and
to try and ensure that we get the
necessary funding we're nowhere near at
that point yet but you are quite right
but on the 16th of March I received a
letter from Rebecca Powell and the
minister confirming the first 41 million
and I should say as well in fairness a
commitment to more but obviously we
don't know how much or how far-reaching
that will be as yet so so some positive
steps but still a long way to go with
this we are of course mandated to
deliver the Cassie Zone by government
direction now in 2022 in order to
achieve compliance by 2020 or and are
there any other questions or comments
before we move on no okay yes of course
and just in relation to the conversation
and they forgive me you know obviously
it's going to be there's going to be
guidance on how we use it and I just
wondered counselor accent we'll looking
you know moving into the 21st century
and taxes and the way people travel
would we be looking at using any of the
funding to to facilitate you know these
cycle rickshaws that we have in other
parts of the country and we don't have
them in traffic it has something
Manchester do and you know it's a thing
that's a very as it's become very
popular in Europe and I just wondered is
that something that you would be looking
at for people traveling locally no
distance response but I mean obviously
uh things like taxes and so forth
justice or specific reforms and we will
use most directives it's something we
could perhaps see Clara some
particularly uh I know sometimes have
these little three-wheeled rickshaws are
they I'm not legally allowed to be used
in this just small local travel and it
would also I'm sure thank you have full
in that interruption hadn't quite
finished I would say is something that
we can look further and it's something
that we we had a briefing update on
Friday that and I'll see we get anything
around those sorts of things but it
depends what the direction is but I'm
happy to look at that further and see if
it's actually within the scope of what
we're doing
thank you it's probably worth me just
saying as I lead on that area the
Greater Manchester but
whilst there are a number of potential
income streams from which we could draw
down for innovative schemes such as the
rollout of rickshaws the cleaner funding
wouldn't be one it is specifically and
there to enable the implementation of
the plan and the support package for
businesses and there are a number of
green initiatives that we sought secure
funding for through the cleaner plan for
instance around electric charging
infrastructure and other such
innovations and we fees all very clearly
by government that this wouldn't be the
place but obviously there is significant
from being starting to come through for
environment lunch transport initiatives
so it may be that other routes come
available to us but not specifically
through the cleaner plan although it's
an alternative form of transport that
certainly IP supportive of as exploring
and thank you for making that report
forest councillor after taking those
questions and the recommendations are
set out in the report conduct agreed
please and cross the bridge and slip it
out please thank you this is a report
for noting it outlines phase one of the
community engagement strategy being
proposed around the potential return of
Sale Sharks to Trafford and the
development of a new community sports
and activity hub on the cross footbridge
site this is a two phase consultation
process phase one launched on the 22nd
of June the scope of this first
consultation phase is set out within the
report and includes amongst other things
an online questionnaire a dedicated
email address for comments and inquiries
online webinars making contact with
schools and over 300 community groups
and their direct mail out to 30,000
homes in the M 33 and M 32 postcodes it
is my view that the consultation process
set out here represents a genuine
exorcising community engagement there
are no detailed proposals no decisions
made phase one is about residents
sporting and community groups helping to
shape and formulate any proposals a
meaningful chance to
have their say I would like to highlight
the balanced tone of this report whilst
we welcome investment into the borough
and the potential for a new sport in a
community facility we also very much
want to hear from the local community
and current users of the site I would
like to say that we recognize and value
the sporting activity already taking
place on cross the bridge and do not
wish to see clubs displaced and left
without a suitable home I note that a
joint statement to this effect was
issued from Sale Sharks and all the
community clubs currently based across
the bridge a couple of weeks ago faith
to of consultation will begin in
September and represents an opportunity
for council tees to help shape more
detailed proposals the results of this
consultation process will be reported
back to the executive in the autumn I
would like to note that the cross road
bridge site is designated as Greenbelt
and protected open space quite
understandably this has already
generated a lot of community interest
and I would urge everyone to positively
engage with a formal consultation
process and take the opportunity to have
their say I'd like to move the report
thank you
Thank You councillor so are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive no okay and questions or
comments more widely councillor Evans as
indicated great thank you thank you
leader and I've been on the council six
years and I haven't known and despite
the fact we've had very similar
proposals in the past I've not no one
that's generated such objections so
quickly but something like you will be a
web some like 2,000 children use this
each week add to that the parents and
add up the residence you probably about
five or six thousand people who are
currently opposed to this there's an
online petition which is gathered at
least three now a thousand signatures
and I'd only there's any irony in the
fact that we just granted their village
green status to turn moss and this egg
Zak has the power at this point really
to knock this on the head and and let
the residents let the
kids let get the trainers get on with
playing football let them enjoy their
summer you've got the power you just say
we are not gonna make this this space
available it's Council and it and you
should do this and just let the
residents have a little bit of peace and
get on with our sonic thank you thank
you for that contribution councillor
Evans and I do know the irony in you
suggesting that you've not known
anything to generate as much controversy
or opposition as this given the history
that your administration found itself in
in its last few years I think the
important point that I would make which
you are well aware of is that there are
no decisions that have been made on this
and that we are asking our community and
our residents and the users of that site
what they think of those proposals it is
fair to say and it can come through very
clearly in community pages in the
correspondence that I have received that
there are very clear views on both sides
of this debate but it is finally
balanced so far in the community but
that there is a clear opposition to this
from as you would expect immediate
residents and indeed many in the
community more widely I think the
difficulty in us saying simply that this
could not move forward councillor Evans
is that this is something that the
council has been discussing now for
three years with sail sharks and indeed
the ambulance-chasing tactics of the
conservative group in trying to jump on
what is not a decision that this council
has made and is a genuine attempt to
engage with our community before any
decisions have been made is noted the
fact that you started these discussions
the fact that it was under your council
cut your political party's leadership
but this council engaged with sale
sharks and now you are objecting to the
approach that we as an administration
have taken which is to pause that and to
ask the community what they think before
any
is in place before any financial
negotiations have commenced and before
any planning application is a moment is
quite embarrassing for you councillor
Evans to be perfectly honest and we have
gone about this in an open and
transparent way by saying to our
community this is something that as an
executive and me as a ward member
actually with my leader of the council
hat on I have to give consideration to
because it could bring investment into
the borough that said I have real
material concerns about this which sale
sharks are aware of they know of my
concerns about noise about traffic about
access about existing usage about the
impact on their neighbors and they also
know because I have set them this as a
test that if this does not carry
community support or if the needs of the
club's currently using the site cannot
be met moving forward then this cannot
proceed and I realize councillor Evans
that it is anathema to the conservative
group to engage in a genuinely open way
and consult with residents before
decisions are made I know that's
something that you will not like I know
that that is something that in 14 years
running the council the Conservative
administration never did but what we are
saying here is this is a significant
proposal for the people of sale we want
to hear your views to help us make that
decision that I think leads to better
decision making and is something that
should not be feared either by residents
or by us as politicians and that is the
point that we are at in this process the
council is not committed in any way I
have not given my support to the plans
we are asking the community what they
think I am listening to those residents
I am engaging with those residents I
have met with the
with bridge management association as
you would expect me to do with something
such as this but it is my job and it is
the job of the executive to look at
anything that could bring investment
into the borough and where we're not
sure and where it doesn't necessarily
sit entirely comfortably as indeed is
certainly the case with this application
in the view of some residents and I
understand that and I hear that very
clearly it seems reasonable to ask the
question I know it's a different way of
doing things but it's something that we
as an administration have done before we
went out with a blank piece of paper to
us residents what they wanted to see
with future plans for Stratford and it's
in a similar vein that we go out now
not with a predetermined for you and not
looking to drive towards a certain
outcome but to say that we can see the
issues with this but having been
introduced by the been conservative run
Council it's something that we want to
hear residents views on and I think that
is a fairly legitimate way to go about
establishing how we move forward with
this and let me say councillor Evans if
it does come back that this is not
supported by our community it will not
proceed it is as simple as that
but you know full well that this council
has never gone out on an issue such as
this at such an early stage and I
watched your administration tie itself
up in knots by arrogantly taking
decisions in the background at turn Moss
at you a 92 at student accommodation in
Stratford at flicks burned fields under
George carnal and that was because you
took those decisions without asking the
community first we will not work like
that as a labor administration and if
residents tell us that they do not want
this to move forward then if they have
my word very clearly now that it will
not do so but I'm not going to be scared
by your campaign on there
I want to hear from residents in an open
honest and transparent way and that is
the process that will unfold over the
next few months so that when we come to
take that decision we can do so in a
truly informed way and councillor
Cobbins did you want to come in please
thank you
and yeah I welcome the early engagement
and consultation with residents in
contrast to other other schemes we've
seen in the past and I have a lot of
concerns as you might imagine about the
fact that this is Greenbelt and a
protected open space and listening
earlier to cancer right he said that any
financial return to a local authority
must be welcomed in the current climate
and I suppose I'm very worried that the
fact that this will bring either and
some sort of income into the council is
canceled on lands that presumably will
be either sold or leased or something to
the sharks and others and will will
typically washing of the the Greenbelt
and further and further down the list at
a time when we are very worried about
air pollution about climate change and
and of course the local residents are
worried about losing the green space
that they know and love and that is at
home to a wide range of wildlife so I
suppose I want some and look for some
reassurance that really this council is
not going to build anything on Greenbelt
except I suppose in the most
extraordinary circumstances where there
is really enormous benefits to the local
community and a second question I just
wanted confirmation on the record if we
could this is not floodplain I know in
some of the discussions it's been am
cited as being floodplain and it wasn't
mentioned in the report as far as I can
tell and my research has indicated
there's not a floodplain so just wonder
if we could get confirmation on that and
I'll leave it at that for now thank you
Thanks councillor copings you'll be
aware that as an administration we have
a very strong record on protecting green
belt land and that is again a reason why
it's right that when we are approached
to consider or indeed when we inherit
an ongoing conversation as we did when
we took over control of the council from
the Conservatives and the appropriate
thing to do with something like this is
to put the brakes on and ask our
community what they think of it the
controversy that comes with any
Greenbelt application that may
eventually come down the line is not
lost on me it really is not I have seen
what happens when you attempt to build
on green belt land without community
support and it simply will not go ahead
if that support is not forthcoming just
on the financial question that you
raised I I did say earlier that no
financial negotiations are ongoing and
that is the case we have not talked
numbers in any way shape or form with
sale sharks and indeed the point at
which we come to make a decision on this
potential scheme would be prior to any
negotiations taking place I certainly
would not be opening any negotiations
with them until we had established the
community you and in line with those two
tests that I said earlier that I had set
for sale sharks around community support
and around the existing users being
catered for moving forward they will be
the sole sole determinants for us in
coming to a decision on this it is true
that it could lead to significant
investment in grassroots sport in
Trafford and it's probably the case
although we're not at that point that
that would be the sort of financial
return that we would be looking at
rather than necessarily a capital
receipt but I couldn't say because those
conversations haven't taken place I'm
not aware of any valuation of the land
having happened for instance
and etc etc I will ask Richard just to
confirm on the floodplain issue I don't
think it is either but I just wondered
Richard people confirm and whether the
land is in floodplain it of course it's
not in the report because the report is
simply to note the fact that we have
agreed to
sale sharps undertaking the consultation
they across with futures so it's not a
report that effectively takes the
decision today it just notes that this
work is happening and that a decision
will be required further along the line
and I don't know Rachel if you're able
to confirm now on the flood plain or if
you'd want to come back to us on that
are you on the line Richard I am on the
line I believe that is correct but I
will double-check and confer and later
just to make sure thank you okay
so she'll finish your hand back off it's
just just briefly just to push you
slightly more on the Bluebell I slightly
worried that and your response seems to
be indicating that we would again be
measuring public opinion as to whether
we should build on the Greenbelt or not
rather than taking and the value of the
Greenbelt as red and and as something
that we need really an enormous amount
of other reasons to overcome that
there's a burden of proof issue we don't
just set out and with an open mind as to
whether we will build on the Greenbelt
or not that we must set out with an
absolute determination not to build on
the Greenbelt unless there is some
really extraordinary reason to do so I
hear what you're saying I think that's a
question that it's right that we ask of
the community but of course you'll be
aware councillor covenants that were
this and is certainly a long way from
that to proceed to planning stage at any
point then any proposals on green belt
land require special circumstances to be
granted so that would would of course be
baiting to any stage of this proceeding
through planning it would need to be
considered an extraordinary matter for
that to be the case we are as I said
instinctively not an administration and
who supports building on Greenbelt
wherever possible and thought it is
right I think that we do ask residents
with an open mind what their thoughts
are on schemes such as this
instinctively
bringing Sale Sharks back to sale I
think feels like a positive thing to do
the question here is whether this is an
appropriate site and the Greenbelt
designation is clearly a really really
important factor in that so it
be very very interesting to see what the
feedback from residents and users is in
the months ahead just to reassure any
residents watching today that this is
some way off a further decision that
whilst I appreciate it will have been
unsettling for this too and have come
forward if you are in their neighbor and
opposed to it or if you are a user and
opposed to the proposals the reason that
we have come out so early is so is not
to commit ourselves without asking for
your views and opinions and that's where
we're at with it we will listen
carefully there is a way to go before
any firm proposals and come to the
executive for a decision and so I would
really encourage residents users etc to
get in touch with ourselves as well as
feeding into the consultation process to
make sure that we know your views
certainly people haven't been shy in
doing that with me over the last couple
of weeks and I really welcome that and
I'm grateful to everybody that has been
in touch so with that the
recommendations are as set out in the
report and may be noted please cognizant
of the fact and I can't see your hand up
I must be on another screen go across I
owe you gaming physically sorry Chris go
ahead yeah yes oh yeah right thank you
yeah yeah I appreciate very much as
what's being said so far about this
particular proposal but I also think
it's appropriate at this point rather
than at a later point that I make one or
two observations and as a small possibly
even irrelevant declaration that I am a
member of sale Rugby Football Club
otherwise known as a Rugby Club which
plays at Haywood Road and that is the
club that was founded in 1861 in fact
I've been a vice president of the club
since 1984 and that's probably just a
couple of years before
leader was born so I do have a sort of
vested interest in rugby in the area and
can assure you that that Club playing
now in national division wand which is
only one one to be a lot of the
Premiership you've got championship and
then national one which is where that
team plays I have to say going on from
that there's two two observations that
I'd like to make really and first is
that in fact Sale Sharks were not
founded in 1861 they were incorporated
on the 14th of March 1997 effectively
when they were formed to actually take
the professional right from the game
that was being played at that stage
which was costing sale Rugby Football
Club six hundred thousand pounds a year
to actually support anyway they they the
playing right of the professional team
was moved from sale Rugby Football
though but not the club itself the club
itself remained and the the professional
game stayed at Haywood Road paying rent
for time and subsequently changed their
names and Sale Sharks of the company
that was used changed its name to
Manchester so rugby club Limited which
is what its entity is now and it
subsequently moved to Friday evening
games with a wish to try and increase
its audience Gate the spectators from
those who played rugby on the staff of
the afternoon so that was the first move
whereby that particular club expanded
its gate on its spectators away from
those who previously have probably
walked to the ground ie people who play
that curse off or who played at metro
Vic's and played even at Broughton path
on a Saturday afternoon would come to
Haywood Road on a Friday night so he
then outgrew that and because the gate
went below about four and a half
thousand they
to stop for under mr. Kennedy you've
taken over the game there stockport
senator stoppable brown so that expanded
their area of spectator support even
further and subsequently as we know
they've moved to the AJ Belle stadium at
Salford I'm sure some of you know
perhaps not all of you that obviously
there used to be a premiership side in
newcastle upon tyne and you guys will
Falcons they're no longer in the friend
ship sails sharks playing itself sharks
at the AJ there are now the only
Premiership side north of Northampton
and Leicester that's the line and
therefore the area from which they now
garner support and indeed from which
they're going to be consulting their
supporters on this consultation is
actually much much more than people who
walked to Haywood Road from the area
around style so it's really no longer a
sail team it's no longer a sail club and
given the most ed about the Premiership
and the area in which it now Garner's
its support from its it really is not
going to be a sailing club I just make
those observations because I think it's
important to recognize that the existing
the original 1861 of one of the first
members of the Rugby Football it was
actually was football I wasn't even
called rugby still remain at Haywood
Road they actually own the training
facility a Carrington to which sail
sharked pay for their training facility
that's owned by the original club not by
sales sharks and was ever said the
Sharks effectively are Manchester say
look people of limited formed on the
14th of March 1997 Thank You leader and
key councillor boys and of course you'll
be a word of that the same could be said
more or less of any professional rugby
team following professionalization in
1997 I think the comments you made car
and broadly valid
slightly tangental in points but
certainly transport will be a key
consideration and indeed is outlined in
the questionnaire I also think I'm right
in saying from correspondence that I've
had with some of the near neighbors
who've been in touch with me that there
is likely to be another northern Club
jewelry joining the Premiership next
year however that won't necessarily mean
that sales and fan base is narrowed in
any way shape or form but as I said we
will go into this with an open mind with
the tests that we have laid down for
Sale Sharks and indeed with the concerns
and then I said around noise traffic and
public transport access and the impact
on their neighbors all weighing heavily
on our mind along with the fact that
this is Green Goblin and indeed the
needs of the existing users of the site
so as I said the report is for noting
only at this point with no decisions to
be made and that be noted please I
item 12 is the period 12 hour turn
budget monitor for 2019 20 so the final
accounts basically more or less for the
last financial year when things were so
much easier in monetary terms councillor
Ross please thank you very much
yes I'm presenting the out turn for both
our revenue and capital budgets from
2019-20
and our position for the year in terms
of the revenue budget is a budget under
spend of 298,000 and that has been
transferred to our budget support
reserve and which the executive to note
the changes in reserve set out in
paragraph 11 which includes the kovaydin
the introduction of a covert 19 grant
support reserve
during which we've allocated 1.39 7
million to the 2019-20
revenue budget and that leaves a
year-end balance in that in that reserve
of 4.7 2 million which vest should will
be applied during this current financial
year
in terms of the capital out turn that
set out from paragraph 23 onwards our
actual capital expenditure for the year
is 38.4 eight million versus a budget of
65 points six three million
obviously much of that will be repro
filed into future budget years and we'll
have some consideration as we find
ourselves going forward with regards to
the changes we may have to make due to
the current pandemic situation so I'd
ask the executive to to devote the
reports and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive and more widely councillor
- yes thank you
Thank You chairman even before Kovach 19
the current year was always going to be
a very difficult year and I note what
councillor Ross is just referred to as
the remaining four point seven million
pounds that would be very useful in that
Cove aid Support Reserve but with the
likely downturn in income from
investments particularly Manchester
Airport with the problem or downturn in
non-domestic rates and possibly even
council tax how soon will the council
need to issue a section 1 month or
notice and then secondly can ask what's
happened to the three hundred fifteen
thousand pound government grant which
was set out to help businesses deal with
brexit thank you chairman right thank
you very much I mean a very very
important question Sun in terms of the
the section moment for obviously there
was some press coverage about that and
other councils I'd say the overwhelming
majority of councils across the country
and it is not the executives intention
to to go you know as - to go to the
point where we be Director of Finance
has to issue a woman for it's not
something that we do as an executive is
something that that Nicky Bishop would
have to do in her her own role and we
are not looking to do that and obviously
you are aware that we do have a
significant shortfall with no indication
of any additional government support
coming through now that shortfall is
around 25 million
moments that again could change given
the income losses that were not lost his
book the income we're not getting as
much in as we budgeted for and the the
costs are related to covert as well so
that could change but our estimates at
the moment is 25 million and what we're
looking at at present is a series of
measures that we can take in year which
would of course then bring to the
executive unto council once we've got to
that stage but it's not in our gift to
issue a 1 1 for section 1 more for that
that that is up to obviously the
director for finance and finance and
systems but we as an executive are that
is not where we are in terms of our
planning in when addressing this this
this current shortfall and once we are
in a position to to look at some
decisions financially around the current
gap we will of course bring them back to
the the executive and to the council in
terms of the the the grant you write
that is that is still sat there brexit
is still happening in the background
though the news is obviously dominated
by bike Ovid I II have to say I promised
you months and months ago officers would
get you an update on that obviously
that's gone by the wayside I apologize
for that Patrick but we will get you
some information about what the current
plans are regarding that and 315,000 so
yeah you'll have my assurance that thank
you
thirteen is urgent business and I think
us was Jo if your handle sorry
Maloney yes leader used to say if we're
moving on urgent business it'd be
helpful if the record you could just
give the reason why you're agreeing
allow the eye surgeon
expert thank you and so as members will
be aware there is now an item of urgent
business the reason for the urgency is
that the approval date for this document
is either today or tomorrow I don't
quite remember which and it relates
directly to our emergency response to
any further local outbreak of Coe birds
so it's clearly in my view and
satisfying the criteria for urgent
business so this is the outbreak
management plan for Trafford that we are
seeking approval for today so members
will note that within the the
information we are asked to note the
content but also know the governance
arrangements around this which will
involve both an internal board made up
of and council officers partners etc but
also a Public Engagement board which I
will be chairing personally which is to
liaise with the public and partners on
where we are at it should we have any
further outbreaks so the operating
management plan is there to ensure that
we've got that multi-agency coordinated
response to responding to outbreaks of
coded in Trafford it's a national
requirement built on the recognition
really that local planning and response
will be critical to success I think
we're seeing now in other parts of the
country some localized outbreaks it's
really important that we have a clear
plan for how we would be or with
anything similar here in Trafford the
idea is that the plan will help enable
us to improve the speed of our response
makes use of the local knowledge that we
have available to us but also improves
that coordination between agencies and
sectors so our plan really focuses on
preventing outbreaks responding to
outbreaks and enable us doesn't really
replace any of our existing plans for
the management of outbreaks but it does
enhance and supplement
he's given the wider impact that we've
all seen the kovat and has been having
on local communities so I hope members
will accept that that was necessarily
urgent business are there any questions
or comments from members of the
executive on this item and any questions
or comments more widely No
okay put the members of the executive
just on you to confirm if they are happy
to approve that report please okay and
that satisfies the agenda and brings us
to the end of the meeting thank you very
much all of you for your attendance and
thank you also to officers who have
enabled a much smoother IT experience on
this occasion so thank you very much
everybody
stay safe and see you all soon
[Music]